and because of the progress that our  county has made the upcoming day in  vegas festival is going to be changing  its health plans so in order to get in  you do have to have the option of either  showing proof of vaccination or a  negative cova test previously only those  who were vaccinated were going to be  allowed into the festival some say  though it's still not worth it we  shouldn't have to be well if you're  tested you can have all the fun and  enjoy all the contests and if you're not  you just have to miss out or get on  board it shouldn't be that way i don't  feel it's fair  now according to the cdc vaccines are  highly effective at preventing severe  disease and death and serious side  effects are extremely rare